white people love protests it's like
going down every other day you've
never felt injustice you had to stand up
for oh you know if I did I can't do
anything about it the condition on my
soon visa prevent me from participating
in political protest no I can't be true
yeah it is Wow I had no I hear you
living under this oppression you're
living under this oppression - what do
you mean you're here on a student visa
alright yeah so let me join
international student yeah but I'm
American okay I'll write to travel with
us guys can I get you to keep walking
cuz we're just gonna shut down this
protest yeah it's fine we're not
protesting it doesn't matter I just need
you to move on so we can clear the area
or what you're gonna beat the out
of us no I'm just asking you to move on
mate it's okay I'm I'm sorry
he just doesn't like people telling him
what to do yo I will move when I'm
goddamn ready to move it not one second
I reckon you start moving right now
champ oh yeah
you just gonna stand here all day now
yeah you can't let people with no
authority push you around that's how
dictatorships happen okay Malcolm X come
on let's go before your visa gets
canceled okay but I'm only moving right
now because I choose to not because I'm
following your instructions
yeah whatever asshole
[Music]
oh hey look they opened a bubble tea
please right into my afterwards bubble
tea the hell is bubble tea bubble tea
you never have bubble tea before no
except floating black it's pulse
and prose on for eating that made-up
tapioca you idiot still looks like
something from Fear Factor you get that
reference yeah no one's gonna try it
right no offense man it's not look good
you left America to not experience any
other cultures yeah that makes sense
hey thanks for stopping by
Oh Jewison Brahmas no I'm okay is this a
shop or what people dump their use food
not fancy enough for a fence he's a
hygiene issue people gonna eat this
right as long as I've been here we've
never had any complaints maybe because
everyone died immediately after eating
it why is it so grubby oh my God look
the fruits someone took a bite out of
this and why does everything look like
she being dragged through the mud
because it's farm-to-table oh the
mouth this is with socially conscious
people on a budget shop whoa why there
no price tags how you know how much
anything cost it's pay what you feel pay
what you feel yeah we have a donation
bowl okay so your business model is
begging got it so why do you they need
to be here just a jover honey calm down
oh what I totally forgot I've been
meeting with professor doe right now to
discuss my essay
so go I have to tell them I can't make
it well because of this no no your first
job is being a student no work and your
parents pay for everything I can't do
uni work if I'm homeless and starving
hello I just cover your shift with it
it's harder than you think what if you
something up there is an open bed of
self-serve yogurt with animal hair in it
I'll tell Todd you're covering my shift
for me just please don't get me fired
trust me our dog back in an hour tops
the whole day if you want we'll see
about that just stand behind the counter
and help customers well I can't hold
customers on the fire joking I'm just
joking see behind the counter
go go go I got it what is this what is
grass jelly red bean and tea oh hey wait
yeah so what's good here
Babu tea what are you having
taro milk tea with taro pudding yeah
I'll get one too first time for
everything right
hey can I get two taro milks you want
pals yeah sure you know what extra pros
go hard to go home right put that
in give change cheers everyone to
international experiences
wait what is this taste it's so clean
even sweet and the pearls chewy
refreshing I've never had anything like
this before
that's its best
what are you doing oh sorry I don't have
any spare change but feel free to take
whatever brought in fruit you want I'm
Todd I should told me we're taking over
as chief Oh Todd yeah yeah thanks for
letting me take open such short notice
no problem how about you start with the
produce over here Oh like stacking it no
rubbing do it on it
people love that Organic fresh from the
ground field with their produce okay uh
here's a crazy suggestion I think more
people would buy the produce if it
looked clean and edible just point out
there we're gonna have a problem here
because I should've asked for you know
yeah yeah of course
I'm sorry you're right whatever you want
a rub where we want onto anything you're
in charge but when you're done with the
produce if you really want to clean
something you can deal with the
self-serve grain station over here Oh
you're mayor throw that out yeah no
problem no I want you to sort through it
you want me to you want me to organize
the grain no pain no grain yo can I get
a passion fruit popping bowl
[Music]
coconut grape jelly with pearls coconut
jelly poppy
[Music]